حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده تقدمها واشنطن
لكيف تشمل لاول مره منظومه صواريخ باتريوت
الدفاعيه هي منظومه دفاع ارض جو تنتقل
بسرعه كبيره
وصواريخ عابره وطائرات تم تطويرها في
ستينيات القرن الماضي في الولايات المتحده
واستخدمت لاول مره في عام 1984
يتم نشر هذه المنظومات للدفاع عن مناطق
معينه مثل المدن الكبيره او الاهداف
العسكريه او البنى التحتيه الحيويه كما
حطت توليد الكهرباء او المصانع
تتمتع صواريخ بتريوت بقدرات كبيره علاوه
على انها فعاله ومكلفه اذ يبلغ ثمن
الصاروخ الواحد ثلاثه ملايين دولار ويبلغ
مداهما بين 40 و 160 كلم في الاثناء
ستتلقى القوات الاوكرانيه تدريبات من قبل
القوات الامريكيه على استخدام المنظومه
خارج
صواريخ
من قبل الامريكيين
مدريد مدريد
اسلحه امريكيه جديده الى اوكرانيا سيؤدي
الى تفاقم الصراع ولا يبشر بالخير